la lucha de Miguel y Sonia contra la
diabetes ha sido solitaria viven en la
comunidad de koayare una de las cientos
que habitan el departamento de guainía
en el este del territorio colombiano
en medio del olvido gubernamental
se encomiendan a Dios
[Música]
y cristianos
en la tierra
a Miguel la amputaron la pierna una
diabetes maltratada afectaba su cuerpo
la enfermedad no lo tomó por sorpresa
también fue la causante de la muerte de
su madre aun así no pudo acceder a
medicamentos para atajarla a tiempo el
doctor no tocan
la rodilla
de este y lo importante es que esto
descansar de este dolor que tengo el
procedimiento no se llevó a cabo en
guainía carente de suministros lo
tuvieron que trasladar a Bogotá la
capital colombiana a casi 700 kilómetros
su situación está lejos de ser única yo
me daba de cuenta ya
otro otro otro otra familia otros otros
países no para que las del
esa gente quedándose en allá sin ningún
calmante hasta que la autoridad de aquí
uno de acá ya como de aquí lo que llegue
el remalo ocho días autorización ya uno
se ha muerto la amputación no trajo
calma esperan una prótesis que luego de
un año sigue sin llegar la enfermedad de
mi esposo
lo quisiera
hablarle así no recordarlo todo lo que
viví con él cuando me preguntaron no que
le ganan la pierna
Ay yo le dije a él no sé porque yo no
siento su dolor mío
usted sabrá Cómo
porque no era así como él está era flaco
flaco flaco la precariedad se siente en
las diferentes latitudes del guainía una
de las grandes dificultades del acceso a
la salud en el departamento es su larga
extensión es el quinto más grande del
país y el más disperso de Colombia con
0,56 habitantes por kilómetro a tres
horas en lancha dividida la capital
departamental se encuentra la comunidad
de berrocal allí la cruz roja ha
encallado su balsa humanitaria un
proyecto que nació para ampliar el
acceso a la salud ante la falta de
servicios hospitalarios y al que acuden
en botes las comunidades aledañas
Stephanie es de manabén fronteriza con
Venezuela
tenía 15 años cuando nació su hijo
freire desde hace días está enfermo
Estefany escuchó de la operación de la
Cruz Roja y emprende un viaje por el río
Orinoco para que el niño fuera tendido
él cuando llegamos a esa comunidad
estamos
en la noche los embarazos adolescentes
son frecuentes en estas comunidades
solo el año pasado la balsa trató 17
casos
y la gente habla
da y yo decía pero no importa el niño no
tiene la culpa la culpa la tengo yo pero
voy a salir todo adelante con mi hija Tú
sabes escribir
un poquito ahí los métodos de
planificación siguen siendo inusuales en
esta zona en 2021 el Ministerio de salud
colombiano mostraba guainía como uno de
los siete departamentos con menor acceso
anticonceptivos
para muchas como Estefani Este es su
primer acercamiento
nerviosa Estoy demasiado luego de
escuchar las opciones
decide Acceder al implante subdérmico
en dos años la balsa prestado servicio a
más de 21.000 personas
desplazándose a las entrañas del
departamento por el río su principal vía
de comunicación el proyecto que es
financiado por la Unión Europea ofrece
atención en medicina general enfermería
nutrición y psicología
Lina Martínez trabaja allí hace siete
meses a diario recibe 35 personas con
todo tipo de enfermedades acá los casos
más prevalentes o enfermedades más
prevalentes que se ven día a día son
enfermedades gastrointestinales como
diarrea vómito enfermedad respiratorias
como tos gripa y enfermedades de la piel
ante la falta de políticas de salud las
comunidades optan por sus saberes
ancestrales
Diana ponte es una de las 55 personas
que viven en berrocal su patio es una
farmacia al aire libre
usa hojas y tallos para curar la persona
que tiene gripe
hay en ese momento cuando la olla está
allá Aquí lista lo llamamos lo
destapamos así como yo le dije lo
dejamos volver así
por eso es ese remedio perfecto para
nosotros los indígenas que vivimos aquí
pero la asistencia médica en guainía
sigue siendo insuficiente muchos mueren
por complicaciones sencillas un malestar
gastrointestinal una cortadura una gripa
Mientras tanto las comunidades esperan
que por el río llegue un sistema de
salud robusto que alcance a todos los
rincones que permanecen a la deriva